bonjour je m'appelle Joël delaclo j'ai
54 ans j'habite à Saint-Paul je suis
auto-entrepreneur j'ai ouvert mon propre
entreprise depuis 1er août 2013 je
travaille dans le bien-être je pratique
des massages et des soins énergétiques
je pratique la réflexologie plantaire le
massage à l'huile je suis praticienne du
premier deuxième degré en soins
énergétique le massage assis et le soin
de l'oreille le massage d'oreilles avec
les bougies OPI mon but c'est de créer
mon mot local hors de ma maison pour
séparer ma vie professionnelle et ma vie
travaille mon but aussi c'est de pouvoir
prendre quelqu'un pour pouvoir
travailler avec moi plus tard et je
compte aussi continuer d'autres
formations pour pouvoir mettre d'autres
massages en pratique les clients m'en
demandent aussi voilà et puis on vit
dans un monde de plus en plus stressé on
a besoin de se détendre de se faire
masser après une journée de travail les
pieds en souffre le corps en souffre le
moral en souffre on a besoin de se
détendre j'en profite pour présenter mon
logo c'est instant cocon c'est un
dépliant qui vous explique un petit peu
tout ce que je pratique comme massage